a la atención electoral de perú que
cuenta con impugnaciones de actas y
acusaciones de fraude se le ha sumado un
nuevo factor dramático el fiscal
anticorrupción ha pedido prisión
preventiva para keiko fujimori la
candidata de extrema derecha con varias
causas abiertas en su contra en 2020
fujimori consiguió la libertad
condicional pero ahora el fiscal josé
domingo pérez pide que vuelva a la
cárcel por incumplimiento de las reglas
de conducta algo que la política niega
así que yo voy a seguir con mis
responsabilidades sin distraer de este
tipo de pedidos a todos a ver adiós sin
sustentos fujimori a está acusada por
varios delitos lavado de activo es
crimen organizado y obstrucción a la
justicia todo a raíz de la financiación
irregular de sus campañas de 2011 y 2016
en las que habría recibido hasta 36
millones de dólares en donaciones de
empresas como la constructora brasileña
odebrecht el marzo pasado el fiscal
pérez pidió una pena de más de 30 años
pero
de 2020 fue puesta en libertad
condicional por riesgo de contraer kobe
19 no obstante una de las condiciones de
su libertad era no reunirse con testigos
del caso abierto algo que fujimori
habría incumplido al respecto su
adversario por la presidencia el
izquierdista pedro castillo aseguró que
el pedido judicial es algo secundario
para él
y vamos
[Aplausos]
el caso que enfrenta no ha impedido que
fujimori se presente a los comicios pero
la causa seguirá abierta a no ser que la
conservadora se convierta en presidenta
y consiga la inmunidad judicial